E aí
e a tecnologia nunca entrou na escola de
fato a pandemia Vimos a escola entrar na
tecnologia a força agora entendemos que
não tem mais volta a tecnologia vai
finalmente entrar na escola mas será que
a tecnologia Pode promover uma
aprendizagem mais humana
e parece uma dicotomia falar em
tecnologia aprendizagem humana e de
certa forma é se pensarmos a tecnologia
como uma máquina mirabolante que faz
download de conhecimento direto para o
cérebro
ou em educacionais que treinam alunos
através de Recompensas como se fossem
ratinho de laboratório
o ou ainda se entender que ela se limita
as aulas remotas como vimos durante a
pandemia reproduzir indo a forma de
ensinar da aula tradicional só que
online
ensinar não é a simples transmissão do
conhecimento
quem sabe aquela ideia de que o
professor é azar que enche o pote vazio
que seria o aluno
o ou como Paulo Freire costumava
criticar chamava de educação bancária
onde o educador
deposita conhecimento na conta do aluno
Eu particularmente sou da linha que
acredita que a gente nem mesmo é capaz
de ensinar no fundo veja bem o que
podemos é criar situação de aprendizagem
e por isso vou focar no conceito de
aprendizagem
muitas vezes esquecemos que aprender é
um processo interno um processo orgânico
que envolve uma mudança biológica é
necessário que o nosso corpo com sua
novas conexões neurais para assimilar um
conceito uma habilidade ou uma
competência
isso só ocorre através de estímulos
corretos e tempo
inclusive dormir é muito importante para
esse processo também não é à toa que os
alunos sente tanto sono estão aprendendo
Afinal
são conceitos bem ser inventados pela
neurociência essas construções complexas
ocorrem de forma incremental por camadas
e por diferentes caminhos em cada
individu
e linguagens com o brilhantemente
abordado por loris malaguzzi e regimilia
onde o próprio título do livro dele já
diz tudo as Cem linguagens da criança
o meu amigo professor Alexandre Rezende
tem uma forma divertida de ilustrar isso
o Olá professor em aula apresenta um
novo conceito uma explicação toda
elaborada muito bem planejada por ele e
aí um aluno levanta a mão disso não
entendi professora
o professor compreensiva calmamente
repete exatamente aquela explicação
Impecável que Ele preparou Afinal tava
perfeita
muitas vezes o aluno ainda não entendi
esse cava e constrangimento Mas você fez
Assistente ele quer entender e aí ele
pergunta de novo ainda não entende
Professor então Professor repete tudo
novamente exatamente da mesma forma
final foi muito bem elaborado só que
agora ele fala mais alto como se o fato
dele não entender tivesse alguma coisa a
ver com não ouvir parece que já vimos
essas cenas vivemos essa cena seja como
aluno com professor
essa cena parece engraçada mas no fundo
é trágica o que o aluno tá pedindo
implorando até São outros caminhos
neurais para alcançar esse novo conceito
ou seja uma forma diferente de explicar
outras linguagens referências
estratégias para que ele possa ancorar
esse conhecimento é algo que ele já
tenha um conhecimento pré-existente
e se não compreendermos isso é fácil
acreditar que serve solução incapazes
por isso a importância tão grande
dispomos diferentes linguagens o
processo pedagógico
agora se aprender um processo interno e
tão complexo ele ainda geram desconforto
no Aprendiz e é natural é preciso sair
da zona de conforto se esporão novo ao
incerto e para superar esse desconforto
é necessário muita energia esforço mesmo
que só acontece com o engajamento
mas atenção nesse ponto observo engano
muito frequente entre educadores quando
se fala de engajamento e crianças logo
pensa que aprendizado precisa ser
divertido e isso é um grande engano
e na verdade o aprendizado precisa ser
prazeroso o prazer vem da realização da
superação de desafios o que muitas vezes
tem de trabalho duro e desconfortável
para aprendiz
e vai no sair se eu gosto de fazer um
paralelo a uma corrida de maratona quem
gosta de correr sabe que a jornada é
dura o maratonista passa a maior parte
do tempo gerei sendo a falta de ar a
fadiga muscular o desconforto o desejo
de desistir
O porém ele sabe que se persistir o
sentimento de prazer vem um da lá no
final o prazer da realização da
superação dos seus limites fazem valer a
pena todos os momentos dificies
e para mim o processo de aprendizagem a
mesma coisa é duro sentir incapaz esses
poucos é mais alunos em sala
experimentar errar lidar com as
frustrações todas mas o que fazemos hoje
na escola para que haja prazer no final
da jornada o aluno quer correta maratona
para tirar uma nota boa na prova no ENEM
lá no futuro o exemplo da maratona
ilustra bem a importância do engajamento
porém importante frisar que não são
todos que gostam de corrida Nem todos se
engasgar com o mesmo objetivo
chegamos então a mais um ponto chave
o mangá já é preciso que seja
significativo para cada um
para isso é preciso de uma relação
emocional com que você está aprendendo
um significado emocional Ou seja que
vale a pena jornada dura da aprendizagem
O que é diferente para cada aluno Vale
ressaltar que o significado de emocional
também vem das relações humanas o
vínculo a segurança estímulo à condução
cuidadosa que o professor oferece a
relação social com os colegas pertencer
a um grupo
cooperar colaborar ensinar e aprender
com seus pares tudo isso é fundamental
para uma jornada significativa e
prazerosa
E olha que interessante Por falar em
prazeroso mais uma vez nem a
neurociência Para comprovar e os
hormônios do Prazer contribuem para
acelerar a criação daquelas conexões
neurais que eu comentei agora a pouco
biológica sabe e esses mesmos hormônios
estão diretamente ligado à formação de
memórias de longo prazo
e observe tamanho importância do
emocional no processo cognitivo então
que temos até aqui estamos falando de
uma aprendizagem humana de fato
E lembra que parte do processo interno
de transformação biológico que passa
pelas diferentes linguagens e
referenciais
O que é sustentada por um engajamento
baseado no significado emocional
Ah e por fim que desenvolve competências
para a vida as ditas competências o
século 21 tão falados ultimamente das
profissões do futuro
nós estamos falando então de um contexto
onde os alunos se apropriam do seu
próprio processo de aprendizagem
desenvolvem competências e estratégias
como o aprender aprender o
autoconhecimento o autocuidado a
criatividade o pensamento crítico
científico analítico entre outros
um ótimo aprendizagem humana e como a
tecnologia Pode entrar nessa história
toda
Olá tudo isso que eu falei não tem nada
a ver com que vimos na aula online
durante a pandemia
Tá certo foram adaptados de forma
emergencial por encontrar essa também
com que observamos historicamente e como
as tecnologias como a robótica ou
informática chegaram as escolas sempre
de uma forma desconectada por elas
mesmas centradas no conhecimento técnico
estruturados em currículos próprios e
atividades puramente executivas como se
o objetivo fosse formar jovens
Engenheiros
o Porém esse laboratório de informática
o mesmo kit de robótica como são
apresentados aos alunos gera uma grande
Euforia e achamos tudo incrível logo
pensamos Essa é a chave para a
transformação da Educação
É mas não somos iludidos pelo que eu
chamo de efeito brinquedo novo aquela
Euforia Inicial que parece ser algo
significativo
mas quando passa a novidade vem o
desinteresse
acabamos vendo somente o interesse de
poucos que bem significado na tecnologia
por ela mesmo
o ou seja são atividades que foram
pautadas na diversão para engajar
e eu entendo que a grande contribuição
da tecnologia da Educação Básica não é o
conhecimento técnico e se a
transformação acontece de fato quando a
tecnologia usada como um meio de
expressão criativa uma linguagem que o
aluno se apropria que da voz e abre
espaço para uma conexão emocional
a tecnologia aplicada como expressão
criativa temos o que eu chamo de efeito
lápis de cor
o que contrapõe completamente com
brinquedo novo a criança não uso lápis
de cor por ele mesmo ele serve como um
meio de expressão criativa ele usa um
lápis para representar suas paixões
desenhar seus familiares seus heróis ou
até mesmo seus medos seus Monstros
o e observe que esse processo
inconsciente de expressão bem sempre
carregado de conexões emocionais do que
é realmente significativo para ela o
tanto que muitas terapias psicológicas
se utilizam do desenho como meio
nós vemos então a tecnologia como um
lápis de cor ou seja uma linguagem que
amplie as possibilidades e trajetórias
de aprendizagem dos alunos
construindo o significado emocional que
torna a trajetória da aprendizagem
prazerosa
E aí
ah lembrando também que a tecnologia tem
um importante papel auxiliar o professor
a criar essas oportunidades de
aprendizagem a valorizar a relação
professor-aluno
viabilizar as diferentes trajetórias por
diferentes alunos uma mesma atividade
avaliar a dar visibilidade essas
trajetórias tudo isso é muito complexo
sem as ferramentas tecnológicas
adequadas
eu entendo que essas abordagens e
ferramentas deve entrar na escola como
forma a integrar os melhores recursos
para promover aprendizagem de forma
totalmente híbrida
eu estou falando de uma aprendizagem
híbrida que não se trata de mesclar
aulas tradicionais e online como muito
tem chamado mas a tecnologia mudando a
forma como aprendizado acontece
quem acredita assim que o grande papel
da tecnologia na educação é dar suporte
ao professor nos processos de
aprendizagem para que de voz ao aluno
contextualizando a sua realidade
repertório carregada de significado
emocional
eu cresci modo temos uma tecnologia
pautada no humano e que se a DECO os
diferentes processos cognitivos Ou seja
abre portas para que o aluno encontre a
sua forma de aprender em forma híbrida
fazendo uso de diferentes linguagens
onde a tecnologia Se integra aos
processos orgânicos e emocionais para
formar indivíduos
e eu estou certo que dessa forma a
tecnologia Pode sim promover uma
aprendizagem muito mais humana obrigado